okay how about this one
friend of the program pepe cuenca
whom i did beat in our banter blitzcap
match
earlier this year feels like an eternity
ago
let's go pepe
almost
oh there we go he's here
let's face him with a sicilian
probably not the wisest choice but who
cares right
[Music]
um h3 will go b5
showing little to nowhere
bishop b7 and g6
i think this is not considered to be
great but
then again who cares
um knight ft7 i suppose
bishop g7 was running into e5
at least i'm making him think
hey force very logical i think i have to
chop that one off
a4 and then bishop g7 if i can
just continue or finish my development
here as i think
i'm more or less have then my position
will be
quite quite sound
there is a weakness on a6 but i don't
think it's
too terrible and besides
that um
it could be imagine that g4 is more
weakness than the strength here think
we'll go rp8
attacking b2 while we have the chance
yeah i was hoping he wouldn't dare to
take any a6 and he hasn't
so good for me
we'll take and then take on b2 i think
it seems to me my position is somewhat
better now
this one oh he's laying a
nasty trap let's say queen c8
then he would go rook takes c6
queen c6 knight d5 with a double attack
knight takes e7 mate and also
threatening my queen
rook and on b2 and i don't think both of
those
can be defended against so i need to
thread a bit carefully
and i think we'll do that by going
bishop b7 back
r7 we'll go knight c5
i think now i should be in the driver's
seat
there's knight d5 now attacking the rook
but i think i've just taken
on c2 with the rook everything's
protected and it looks fine
yes take that one
knight b4 attacks the rook which leaves
which leaves it a bit short of squares
but i've had
would have had 96 then rook returning to
c7
protecting everything
now after this move e5 geological of
course
opening up i think we take it
we chop off the knight which could be
dangerous
and then we chop off some more we go e6
and uh i think
i think here i have a considerable
positional advantage as well as an extra
pawn
so i should be able to win this at least
in practice
and now we have a little tactic rookie
four
i didn't see rook d1 though it was a bit
unfortunate but in general i should win
speaking of little tactics i think
knight h3 works
king g2 there's rook f4
g3 we go rook f6 back
saving the knight knight f2 there's rook
d2
so we need to be a bit careful so we go
knight of four instead
um there's about three h6 and
everything's protected
now it should be plain sailing knight g6
regrouping we bring the other rook
rook b3 with the size of threats
that's game over okay
good good good i think a fairly decent
game there
no atrocious blunders and
fairly reasonable strategy